please for the love of God I want a
country artists so bad because I love
country music
calling all country Arctic I want to
work with you but everybody always
thinks that Blake is the only option
everyone countries to steal a country
this one Blake is almost impossible
Kelly is definitely my main competition
when it comes to country artists Hey
not really but she thinks she is I've
experienced the pain and torment that
Kelly is feeling right now she's just
taking the bait that I've taken for
years I'm right here to support her she
needs me honestly think I have a chance
that's the worst part it's fine I'm not
mad I'm gonna coach her through this
because you're gonna need my help all
right deep breaths less talking and
honestly don't attack him because
that'll just make him more sympathetic
to Blake now that Adam has retired from
pushing his button for country artists
somehow he feels like that's made him an
expert and coaching the other coaches
don't get lured into his nonsense he's
gonna point some venom at you you look
at me when he does it don't look at it I
told her to calm down deep breaths I'm
thinking I don't want a coach that needs
another coach to coach them through a
blind audition sounds like a winning
plan we are Blake
success in country music I know a lot of
country artists my husband manages Blake
I'm still gonna fight I will go down in
a flame of glory try I pick Kelly yes
but she got do I like to think about
some of it my fantastic advice it's
pretty good to be wait Adam gets a major
assist on my country when I got the
exhalation do you think because I need
some too congratulations Kelly
[Music]
you